NAOUM FARES MARAYATI:
The main way
that my Princeton
experience has shaped
me is to become in the service
of humanity -- whether it
was in my career, what
I'm doing on campus --
I really strive to be
in service of everyone.
My name is Naoum Fares Marayati.
I go by Fares.
I'm Class of 2019, and
I'm studying psychology.
I'm originally
from Aleppo, Syria.
I used to visit New
Jersey when I was young,
and I finally settled in
North Carolina in 2012.
I've always been interested
in the way humans think,
the way we interact with each
other, and the way our brain
works.
I took a cognitive psychology
course my freshman fall,
and then took a psychology of
language course my freshman
spring.
I realized that it was something
that I really enjoyed doing.
It was always the first
thing that I started
reading when I came back home.
I also started working
in the Baby Lab.
It all just came together,
and I found my path.
CASEY LEW-WILLIAMS: I
met Fares three days
before his freshman year.
I was at the
undergrad expo, which
is Princeton's event
for new freshmen
where they can learn about
concentrations and apartments.
And Fares came up to
the psychology table,
and I introduced myself.
And he said, oh, you
directed the Baby Lab.
I know about your work.
He also immediately
gave me the impression
that he is an
intellectual force,
that he is somebody who
contributes to the community,
that he has an
enterprising spirit.
And every interaction I've
had with him since then,
whether in the lab or
over a meal at Forbes
College or Butler College,
has truly confirmed that.
He is a gift to our lab.
NAOUM FARES MARAYATI:
The Princeton Baby Lab
is a group of
incredible people that
work together to study child
development and perception,
more specifically the way
children acquire patterns.
Babies are statistical
learning machines.
They perceive the world in
such unique and amazing ways.
And the lab just tries to
answer that same question
from different approaches,
based on different graduate
students that work there and
the different professors.
[SINGING]
Outside of the Baby
Lab, I am a baritone
for Umqombothi, Princeton's
premier African a cappella group.
I am also a tutor at McGraw,
and I am a tour guide
for the University Art Museum.
[SINGING]
I'm very involved in
Forbes, my favorite community
on campus.
I'm a peer academic adviser.
I served on the Forbes
College Council,
and I will also be an assistant
residential college adviser
next year.
Being involved in
Forbes has really
strengthened the community feel,
and Forbes has become my home
very quickly.
It's very comforting
to know that at the end
of the day, when all my classes
are over, when all my work is
over, I can just go back home.
Princeton has just been
surreal, and I still
can't believe that I go here.
But it was just an incredible
opportunity that I was given.
I couldn't have done
it without the help
of so many people in my life.
And yeah, I just rose
to the challenge.